ON HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CUPBOARD NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AT HERE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS IN NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8152 AGAIN.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FIVE FIVE. FOUR ONE
EIGHT THREE AGAIN THE ACCESS
EIGHT THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE A MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOUR WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSEDESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE DRUG
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE MATTER C. MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL PART
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA HOWEVER WE ARE
NOT HEARING AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY NINE BY
SOME MEMBERS MEHR THIRTEEN
CENTS ON THIAGO. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT SENATOR TODD- IT
WILL NOT BE PRESENT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING AND THAT WE HAVE THREE
BILLS UNDER CONSENT UNDER.
WHICH WE WILL VOTE ON AT THE
END OF THE HEARING AND WE'LL
NOT BE HEARING TESTIMONY ON AND
THOSE ARE ITEM NUMBER NINE.
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY TWO BY SUMMER
WALDRON ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
TWELVE EIGHTY BY SAM IRWIN AND
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
SERVAN TASTES. UNLESS A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE WISHES TO
ATTEND- WITHDRAW THOSE BILLS.
THE BILLS WILL BE HEARD AND
FOLLOWER THE ORDER MAY BE
MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE VEIL
ABILITY OF BILL AUTHORS TO
PRESENT. THE NEED TO COMPLETE
THE HEARING AGENDA AND A TIMELY
MATTER. BEFORE WE PRESENT HERE
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL- WE
WILL SEE ABOUT ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM ARE WE READY TO DO THAT
YET. OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF- MEMBERS. CAN HEAR. AND HEAR
MELINDA'S. HERE LINDA'S HERE
AIKMAN GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HERE
GROVE. HERE GROVE HERE HER TADO
LEYVA. HERE LEAVE A FAIRLY MON.
ROTH HERE ROSS HERE RUBIO.
WE'LL BE OUT HERE WINNER. WITH
ONE I COULD ADD ALL NOTES ARE
CORN HAS BEEN THIS. FOR BILL
TESTER DO CAN OF LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TO CAN INCLUDING THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR INSTITUTE
TIMELY ON TESTER. EACH SIDE OF
THE LOOP THE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR MYSELF FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AS IS CUSTOMARY
WILL COMMIT UP TO TWO WITNESSES
FOR TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS AND
A MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES ON
EACH SIDE FOR TESTIMONY. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES I HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE HAVE
A DEFINITE IN TIME FOR THE
HEARING I MAY LIMIT THE TOTAL
TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS ON A BILL
TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEE'S. ABLE
TO COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERY ALSO THE UPPER.
SOME TEST AND ON ANY BUILDING
HEARD TODAY ON THE COMMITTEE.
BUT THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN OUR GENDER.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER
RAMBLE AND I SEE THAT HE'S HERE%
WELCOME- PLEASE BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND SENATORS. RACISM IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
PAINFULLY WITNESSED WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO OUR IMMIGRANT BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO BORE THE BRUNT
DURING THE LAST PANDEMIC. WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO WAIT ON THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION TO PASS
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM WHICH IS TAKEN TOO LONG
AND PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC RACISM
WE MUST ACT WITH URGENCY NOW.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LEGACY OF
LEADING BY EXPANDING HEALTHCARE
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE EXPANDED MEDICAID COVERAGE
TO UNDOCUMENTED KIDS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE INCLUDED YOUNG
ADULTS AND NOW EIGHTY FOUR WILL
CONTINUE IN THIS VEIN BY
EXPANDING EDICAL COVERAGE TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS. SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL
ENDS THE EXCLUSION TO HEALTH
CARE ACCESS DUE TO IMMIGRATION
STATUS BY REMOVING IMMIGRATION
STATUS AS AN ELIGIBILITY
BARRIER TO MEDIC CAL CALIFORNIA
CAN BUILD A MORE UNIVERSAL
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
FOR ALL WHO CALL THIS STATE
HOME. NOW IS THE TIME FOR US TO
BE ANTI RACIST TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND TO INVEST IN
ALL CALIFORNIANS ESSENTIAL
NEEDS TO ACHIEVE EQUITY AND
HEALTH CARE ACCESS. AFTER
BATTLING THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
OF THE CENTURY WE MUST PROVIDE
THESE TAX PAYING CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR
ECONOMY AND SOCIAL FABRIC FOR
DECADES WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED TO BE HEALTHY AND
SAFE. WE INVEST IN THE HEALTH
OF OUR STATE WHEN WE INVEST IN
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR LOW INCOME
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS WHO ARE IN
THE CENTRAL PART OF OUR
WORKFORCE AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
NOW IS THE TIME TO ACHIEVE
HEALTH CARE EQUITY AND HEALTH
CARE ACCESS BECAUSE WELL WE
KNOW THAT TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
HEALTH OF EACH OF US IS
DEPENDENT ON THE HEALTH OF ALL
OF US. I AM JOINED TODAY BY TWO
WITNESSES FIRST CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADER DOLORES HUERTA PRESIDENT
AND FOUNDER OF THE DAUGHTERS
WORK THE FOUNDATION. AND
LILLIAN SERRANO A. COMMUNITY
MEMBER WHO WILL SHARE HER STORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REMEMBER. A
REGULAR- SO MODERATE- PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINE- DELORES
WORKED- ON. FOUND PRESS THE
DOORS WERE WERE FOUND AND LOUIS
SIRI AND I BELIEVE GOING TO BE
WITH- BUT WORSE WE'RE A YOU
HAVE MINUTES A TOTAL FOR MANY
FOR BOTH OF YOU- SO IF THE ONE
FIRST PERSON GOES OVER I'LL BE
A LITTLELESS TIME FOR THE
SECOND PERSON TO JUST KEEP THAT
IN MIND I'LL ANNOUNCE A-
CONCERT ANNOUNCED WE GET TWO
MINUTES SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
HIT THAT POINT- SO AGAIN
MODERATE COMPLETE PLEASE BRING
ONLINE DEALER SUPPORT. DORSET
ONLINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I THINK OUR
YOUNG GENTLEMAN WORKED ON I
WANT TO THANK THE SON OF THE
CHAIR ABOUT THE- AND ALL OF THE
SENATORS AT A HEARING THAT WILL.
AND ASKING IF SUPPORT THE HELL
CARE FOR ALL BILL EIGHT FOUR.
WE KNOW THAT THE GOOD AND WITH.
OF OUR TAXPAYING HELD. THE LADY
COMFORTABLE BECAUSE WERE BORN I.
BECAUSE IT COULD NOT BASED ON
THEY WERE BORN IN- YOU KNOW
THEY ARE. PEOPLE WORKING AT A
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT WORKERS YOU
CAN'T CAN'T HELP FOR. CLEAN AND
STRAIGHT AND THEY CAN TO BUILD
THE SITE EITHER THE ARE BETTER
FROM SECOND MONEY ABOUT CHARTS.
NOT ONLY THE WAR THAT THEY-
ALTHOUGH WITH THEWITH THE- AS
CAN. AND ATTACK OF THE THREE OF
WHICH ACCOUNTS TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF. YOU CAN. IT WAS
REALLY WONDERFUL TO SEE THE
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT. OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS BOTH ARE REALLY
HAPPENS AND THE SUPPORT THAT WE
HAPPEN TO SUPPORT MEASURES SO
WE KNOW THE CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
HAVE TO BE FIRST IN THE NATION
I THINK THAT WE COULDN'T DO
THIS. IT IS NOW TIME TO ENTER
THE EXCLUSIONS AND PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL THANK YOU
THIRTY EIGHT ONE WE KNOW THAT
REALLY IN ORDER FOR ALL OF US
TO BE HEALTHY WE CANNOT EXCLUDE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I'LL PUT
THAT NOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I NOW PLEASE BRING
THE LIEN SERRANO ONTO LINE. YOU
KNOW SO THAT- MYSTERON AS
DIALED IN. OKAY RIGHT WELL-
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE TO
TAKE- TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FROM
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND THEN
WE'LL SEE AT THE END HETHER
MISS- WITHIN SERRANO WAS COME
BACK ON- SO WOULD NOW- LET'S
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NAME POSITION
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON UP AT THE PUBLIC
OUTLETS ROOM. MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- ACTUALLY. IT'S
LIKE A DIFFERENT ROOM- SO- NO
ONE IN THE ADDITION OF THE
SECOND ROOM- ACTUALLY THERE FOR
WHICH ROOM IS THAT. WHICH ROOM
IS THAT. BUT SERVICEABLE ROOM
HERE ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL
THE ONES IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE- MODERATOR
IN THE- TOOTH ON THE TELEPHONIC
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FOUR WHICH THAT'S
WHAT I SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
LATER JOHN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND
AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY SO-
MODERATE JUST PLEASE LET THEM%
TESTIFY AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. ABSOLUTELY AND
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO
REMEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXUS FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
HEALTH NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT IS TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A NUMBER
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NICKLES TO NUMBER FIFTY SIX
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND CHILD SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. MMHM ABSOLUTELY.
NEXT WE HAVE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CRADLE CODDLE ON BEHALF OF HIS
CLIENT THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND PART OF ME
BEFORE. I THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT IS THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON KAREN I'M
REJECTING RANDOM THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DOCTOR PANEL
MEMBERS ENGAGED YET ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO
NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DIDN'T EVEN BUT I I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIAN AGAIN
POLICY CENTER STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK BOBBIE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SALLY CHAIN
WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER IN
STOCKPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT IS NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT WE GO
TO NUMBER SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT. ON BEHALF OF
YOUNG INVINCIBLES IN FULL
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXUSLINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DR PEPPER'S
OFFICE PRESENTABLE THE WEB YOU
KNOW COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA CALLING IT A STRONG
SUPPORT PAY BEFORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- THOROUGHBREDS N
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RESEARCHER MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BEFORE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TIME. NEXT
IS SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIREBRICK LATER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE REPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERYL MEMBER
THE WHOLE THEY PARTED WITH
HEALTH TECHNICAL KOREA SPONSORS
OF EIGHTY FOUR COMING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. Q. NEXT LINE. NEXT TO
NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DIMITRI SEE
WHAT THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL ORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER SHOWING SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
ONE IS FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BECAUSE
THE REST AFTER RETURNING
CALLING THE DOCTOR FOR A BABY
FOR. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. SIX
IS THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
REALLY LOOK. AND THIS YOU KNOW.
ONLY CALLING IT SUPPORT THE
MAYBE FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SO WITH ST JOHN'S
WELL CHILD AND FAMILY CENTER
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
SOON HE KNEW HOLLYWOOD
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG IN TERMS OF PHOTOS IN
THE FALL. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
MYANMAR ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATTEO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. TEXAS FORTY ONE
IS JONATHAN CARTER CALLING FOR
AN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINDING EVERYTHING
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IT
FOLLOWING INSURANCE FOR A BABY
FOR THINKING THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. NEXT THREE NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN A NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KEVIN DOUGLAS
WITH GRANT MAKERS CONCERNED
WITH IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER THIRTY- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS ACCOUNT AGAIN FROM
YOUNG INVINCIBLES CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN- PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KATIE CALLING FROM
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXLINE. NEXT WE NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US ALL THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE MADE A TREMENDOUS
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LOOK AT YOUR
PLATONIC ARE CALLING INSTRUCT
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
FORTY. HI THIS IS FAYE DOCTOR
LIVES ABOUT CALIFORNIA
INDIVISIBLE STAYED STRONG AND
INDIVISIBLE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE EIGHTY TWO. ONE
EIGHTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO
MY NAME IS ALEX- HIGH AND-
REPRESENTED ENGLAND POLICING
FOR IMMIGRANT CHAPTER EIGHT IN
ORGANIZATIONAL POLLUTION MORE
THAN FORTY ARE IMPATIENT AND
MILAN AND FIRE I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE. EIGHTY THREE.
LINE EIGHTY THREE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S ALAN AND
UP INTO THE MIDDLE. AND I'M
CALLING TRUMP A CORPORATE
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. LINE. EIGHTY FIVE.
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE EIGHTY SIX. HI GABRIELLE
LESSARD ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER
IN LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT IN LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. MY NUMBERS BUT
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EACH ONE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AMANDA SHOCKER AND I'M
CALLING FROM CALLING A STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THIS IS
CLOUDY SAVVY THEN FROM CENTRAL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT IS NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRYING
WITH THE MARKET. CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTED FORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH NOW WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO SOMEBODY OPPOSITION WE DO
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. LISTED FOR- TESTIMONY
SO BEGIN GO ON
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO A
BEFORE BEGINNING WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE NO ONE
PUBLIC ALLEY THAT'S MOVED TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM
TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FOUR. FAMILY'S GERMAN IF YOU
ARE AN OPPOSITION DAY BEFORE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO PROPOSITION.
I DO SHOW ONE IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ACTUALLY IN THE STEAK I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE SUPPORT- AND I DON'T KNOW
WHY I GOT INTO TOP CONDITION MY
NAME IS MARINA LONG. IT FROM
AGEING RETURNING TIME AND IN
THE STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
FOUR OKAY I THINK I WAS PUT IN
THERE IT'S WRONG TO USE FOR THE
OPPOSITION AGAIN THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE RECENTLY
REGISTERED YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHTS ARE THERE ANY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY FOUR. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO IT'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
THANK- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IKNOW
YOU'RE WORKING IN TANDEM WITH
WITH OUR WITH OUR HOUSE AND
SPECIFICALLY SENATOR THE
RUSSELL- BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW INCREDIBLY IMPACTFUL THIS
IS AND I WAS PREACHING TO THE
CHOIR HERE AS YOU ARE AT. A
PHYSICIAN BUT- SO VERY
IMPORTANT FOR DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE IN SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES
WHERE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
LIVE AND WORK AND PAY TAXES IN
THE GIVING INTO. A SYSTEM THAT
IS UNFORTUNATELY NOT GIVING
BACK TO THEM SO WITH THIS I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH-
AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND CO
AUTHOR ON. ON YOUR END AS WELL
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. REMEMBERS OKAY YES
SIR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FALL RATE- I
THINK THIS IS JUST THE DECENT
THING TO DO WHEN I THINK OF
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES- AND I
HAPPEN TO HAVE BEEN LAUNCHED IT
IS THE DECENT THING TO DO AND I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE
INVEST. IN OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
STUDENTS YOU KNOW WE WANT THEM
TO BE HEALTHY TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND I THINK THAT THAT
YIELD LONG TERM BENEFITS
EDUCATED INDIVIDUALS MAKE FOR A
BETTER WORKFORCE MORE DECENT
HUMAN BEINGS AND I THINK THAT
COLLECTIVELY I THINK THAT WE
ALL BENEFIT FROM A HEALTHY
SOCIETY BEING KILLED. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- SO
WHATEVER BRAMBLETT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- AS A FELLOW PHYSICIAN
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THAT NOT
ONLY OF COURSE IS THAT THE RATE
DECENT THING TO DO THAT HAVE
PEOPLE HAVE THIS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE THAT ALSO WHEN
PEOPLE ARE DENIED ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE AS WE'VE EXPERIENCED
IN CODED THAT ONLY DANGERS
THEMSELVES ACTUALLY DANGERS OF
COMMUNITY AT ARGE. SO
CERTAINLY I AND- IN STRONG
SUPPORT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU DR PAM FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU- I DO NEED A MOTION.
OKAY IT'S MOVED BY SARAH
GONZALES THE MOTIONS TO PASS
THE FIRST THREE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S NOBLE
AND IS NO BIG MEN. BY ADMIN
AIKEN SOUTH HI IT'S AWESOME I
GROWTH NO GROWTH NO HER TADO.
LLEVA HI LEAVE A EILEEN MOANED.
ROTH BY RAFA I RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER. WINNER I. SO THE
COROLLA SEVEN TWO WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL ALL RIGHT LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO- ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY FAR AGAIN
BY SUMMER RAIN DELAY- PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU DR CANNON
SENATORS SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS S. EAT PEAS HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL IN REDUCING HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN
CALIFORNIA. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WILL PROTECT THESE VITAL
SERVICES BY PROVIDING THESE
PROGRAMS WITH AN EXEMPTION TO
SEE CORE REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A RISE IN DRUG
RELATED HARMS INCLUDING
OVERDOSE DEATHS HEPATITIS C.
DIAGNOSIS RATES AND INCREASED
RATES OF POTENTIAL HIV
TRANSMISSION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES.
ACCESS TO STERILE SYRINGES
REDUCES HIV AND VIRAL HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS WHILE BEING SAFE
EFFECTIVE AND COST SAVINGS.
CALIFORNIA S. C. PEAS PROVIDE A
WIDE RANGE OF SERVICES IN
ADDITION TO SYRINGE ACCESS AND
DISPOSAL INCLUDING HIV AND
HEPATITIS TESTING. OVERDOSE
PREVENTION TRAINING AND
REFERRALS TO DRUG TREATMENT
HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THESE SERVICES HAVE
HELPED GARNERED THE TRUST IN
PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE
SEEK OUT HARM REDUCTION
SERVICES. BUT RECENTLY
UNEXPECTED LEGAL CHALLENGES
HAVE ARISEN DESPITE THE CLEAR
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE THAT
THIS SECTION IS TO OPERATE
NOTWITHSTANDING. ANY OTHER LAW.
ON IN ORDER COUNTY HAS
INTERPRETED AS HE PEES AS
PROJECTS SUBJECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
COULD NOT DEMONSTRATE THAT I
COLLECTED ALL THE SYRINGES
DISTRIBUTED. SUBSEQUENTLY THE
PROGRAM WAS FORCED TO SHUT
DOWN. ANOTHER PROGRAM IN BUTTE
COUNTY HAS BEEN FORCED TO
RESEND THE CDPH APPROVED
APPLICATION IN THE FACE OF
SIMILAR LITIGATION.
ADDITIONALLY A SIMILAR LAWSUIT
HAS BEEN FILED AGAINST AN S. E.
P. AND SANTA CRUZ IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE MUST BE
REMINDED THAT THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO EXPAND AS HE
PEES IN OUR STATE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUR LOOMING OPIOID
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. DURING
THE PANDEMIC THERE'S BEEN A
SHARP INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS AS EVIDENCED BY THE CDC.
THE NEED FOR ACCESS TO SERVICES
PROVIDED BY NCP'S IS NOW
GREATER THAN EVER. THESE TYPES
OF SUITS ARE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
REQUIRING SEQUEL REVIEW OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
IMPROPERLY PLACES DISEASE
PREVENTION ND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AT ODDS. WITHOUT
IMMEDIATE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION
SERVICES PROVIDED BY C. S. C.
P.'S DIRECTLY AUTHORIZED BY
CITY PH WILL BE CURTAILED AND
NEW PROGRAMS WILL BE DETERRED
AT THE PERSON HI THE PRECISE
TIME. WHEN THE NEED FOR THEM IS
INCREASING. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WILL HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE RAPID
SPREAD OF HIV HEPATITIS OR ANY
OTHER POTENTIALLY DEADLY OR
DISABLING INFECTIONS THAT ARE
SPREAD THROUGH THE SHARING OF
USED NEEDLES AND SYRINGES BY
PROTECTING THESE VALUABLE
COMMUNITY BASED S. C. PEAS. I
AM JOINED TODAY BY WITNESS
MARICELA SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
AT THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE. HI
THANK YOU SENATOR AMIDALA
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE VERY SIMILAR FROM THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. HI I'M HERE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN. GREAT
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MERRY SO AND I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION AND ATTEMPT
TO CREATE ANIMATION. THREE
DOCTORS IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GOOD AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE WELL AWARE. OF
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
CURRENT EXCHANGE PROGRAMS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH
THEY REDUCE HIV AND HEPATITIS
C. TRANSMISSION AND ENGAGE WITH
REGARDS TO THE TREATMENT AND
REDUCE THE OVERALL DRUG USE.
DURING SERVICES PROGRAMMES DID
MORE THAN JUST PROVIDE SYRINGES
IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
DISTRIBUTE THE OPIOID ANTIDOTE
NALOXONE TO PEOPLE WHO USE
DRUGS AND THEY PROVIDE LNKAGE
TO DRUG TREATMENT AND SOMETIMES
SERVICES ON SITE ENTERING CODED
EVERLIGHT KOBE TESTING
VACCINATION. PREVENTION
EDUCATION AND EVEN PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR IF
NECESSARY. TO KEEP THE DOORS OF
THE PROGRAM. YES THAT WAS THE
TURNING YOUR DIFFERENCE. HI NOT
SUBJECT TO. NOW AND BACK SEVEN
YEARS OF UNDER A LAW WE ARE
HEADED DAN AND WE KNOW SKINNER
HE PETER GIVE ME A TO. APPROVE
STRENGTH OR PROGRAMS THE-
TWENTY TWO EIGHT AND IT WAS
FOUGHT AGAINST THE PH AND THREE
DIFFICULT KNOWLEDGE ARGUING
THAT THIS NEW TO DEFER UNDERGO
A THOROUGH REVIEW ON YOUR C.
CLASS. FOR THE TRIAL COURT IN
THAT CASE RULED THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE SUBJECT TO BE
QUIET AND ON FAMILY JUDGMENT
SAID THAT IT NEEDED TO BE
CONSIDERED THAT RESULTED IN THE
CLOSURE OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAM. DR
ANGELA SAID THIS HAS LED TO
OTHER PROGRAMS CLOSING IN CHICO
AND NOW ONE CAN ACCRUE THOSE
UNDER LEGAL THREAT ONE OF THE
MAIN COMPLAINT OF THOSE
OPPOSING PROGRAM IS THE FALSE
IMPRESSION THAT SYRINGE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS CONTRIBUTE
CHOOSE YOUR FRIENDS LATER WITH
IMPORTANT NOW THAT WE NEED TO
WAIT IS NOT. INCREASED BY. A
RESEARCH HEARING AND YOU THE
COUNTRY IS DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
RANGE WEIGHT REDUCED INCREASE
TWENTY HAVE ACT TO THE PROGRAM
WHEN PEOPLE DRUGS HAD A FACE
PLACE DISPLAY INCLUDED THANK
YOU SIMPLY PUT YOUR INJECTION
JUST PART OF THE FILM GESTURING
WAIT NOT OF THE PROBLEM. THANK
VERY SENT PROGRAMS AND MORE
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH I NEEDED A LITTLE BREAK
ON THE THEY'RE GREAT FOR THE
DOCTOR AMBULATORY CARRINGTON
EXCEPTION FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
COME ON EVERY DRIVER I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANYTHING TO YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A RIGHT WE'LL FOR
THE OPPOSITION TIME. WITH WILL
MOVE TO DIGITAL WHAT AND- OF
THE WITH PUBLIC GALLERIES SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC ALICE MOVED TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SINGLE IN ROOM
TWELVE. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES TO WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
PLEASE YOUNG MEN IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE EUROPE YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. THE B. JUST A MOMENT
HERE. WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
IN OUR QUEUE. THANK. THEY'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE GET
THEIR NUMBERS OKAY. AND WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER RODRIGUEZ
I'LL BE HAPPY EASTER YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY INSTRUCTED
PORT EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
TO THE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LESLIE BASKETS WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO THE NUMBER NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT NUMBER
NINETY SIX IS WHAT THE QUEUE
OKAY. NEXT LINE. BUT WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE QUEUING UP TO BE JUST
A MOMENT OKAY. THEN WE'LL GO TO
NINE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON GOING
BACK TO SPELL BIGGER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU EXCELLENT. YEAH
WE'LL GO BACK TO NUMBER NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY.
SPORT THANK YOU THANKS LINE. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE THE NINETEENTH THANK
YOU MODERATOR- NOW LET'S BRING
ON OUR LEAD- OPPOSITION
WITNESS- TALK TO MOST- BUTTE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR US A
MODERATELY PLEASE BRING A
SUPERVISOR COME WITH YOU ON TO
THE LINE. MR KIMMEL SHOE IS ON
THE LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YEAH
GO AHEAD YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TWENTY SEVEN SECONDS. PLEASE
AGAIN. THANK YOU. YOUR CHAIRMAN
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
FILLED MY NAME'S TODD HIMANSHU
WHO CARRY SUPERVISOR VIEW
COUNTY. YOU CAN ONLY POSES A
TEMPLATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO EXEMPT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORIZATION A SYRINGE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS FROM SECRET
PROCESS. ONE OF THE MOST SOLEMN
OBLIGATIONS OF GOVERNMENTS AT
EVERY LEVEL IS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AND TO
ENSURE THE ENVIRONMENT REMAINS
PRISTINE AND LITTER FREE AS
POSSIBLE BOTH FOR CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. NEEDLE
LITTER IS AN UNAVOIDABLE
CONSEQUENCE OF THE LOOSELY
REGULATED DRUG PARAPHERNALIA
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHICH HAVE NO REQUIREMENT
TO EXCHANGE USED NEEDLES FOR
CLEAN ONES. WHILE C. E. P. H.
SIX TO EXEMPT THEMSELVES FROM
THE CONSEQUENCES THE DANGER TO
THE PUBLIC REMAINS. FAMILIES
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN MUST NOW
WORRY ABOUT THE DANGER OF
POTENTIAL NEEDLE STICKS WHEN
VISITING PLAYGROUNDS PARKS AND
WATERWAYS. THE IMPACT THE
SUPPER ARE JUST AS REAL AS HIV
AND HEPATITIS THE- DO YOU
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF CHICO IN
PARTICULAR HAVE EXPERIENCE
NEEDLES BEING DISCARDED IN MANY
OF THESE AREAS IF THIS IS NOT
AN ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD I'M NOT
SURE WHAT IS. YOU COUNTY AND
ALL FIVE INCORPORATED CITIES IN
BUTTE COUNTY. ORDINANCES TO BAN
ANY NEEDLE DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAMS AND TELL. IF THE
RULING PARTY MENTAL REVIEW CAN
BE COMPLETED. BUTTE COUNTY
STRONGLY ENCOURAGES THIS
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SEEK WHAT. THE SEQUEL PROCESS
IT'S PART OF BEING EVEN LEGAL
OR DRUG. THE MAIL YET
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SUPERVISOR WILL NOW MOVE TO
DIGITAL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC ALICE MOVED TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM
ONE TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO FIFTY
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. AND NOW HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S NOW
BRING IT BACK TO ME- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER WINNER. I THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL- NEEDLE-
EXCHANGING THE DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAMS- OR LIFESAVING- DAILY-
REDUCE. HIV AND HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS THERE'S REALLY NO
LEGITIMATE ARGUMENT AGAINST THE
EFFICACY OF THESE PROGRAMS-
NEEDLE EXCHANGE- ORIGINATED IN
SAN FRANCISCO DURING THE WORST
OF THE AIDS. CRISIS IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES NINETEN
NINETIES WHEN IT WAS COMPLETELY
ILLEGAL AND THE CITY FINALLY
WAS. ABLE TO GET AUTHORIZATION
FROM THE STATE BUT- YOU KNOW
THIS IS- THERE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTION BY EVEN SOME
CONSERVATIVE ARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE RESISTED IT
HAVEENDED UP IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROGRAMS WHEN HIV EVEN
RUNS OUT OF CONTROL- AMONG IV
DRUG USER POPULATIONS- AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH WE SEE-
CONTINUING PUSH BACK FROM SOME
IN THE COMMUNITY- AND I THINK
SOMETIMES THERE'S THIS FALSE
PERCEPTION THAT. HAVING A
NEEDLE EXCHANGE ANY OF THIS TO
BE SOME PROGRAM IS SOMEHOW
GOING TO CAUSE PEOPLE TO START
INJECTING. DRUGS WHICH IS
COMPLETELY FALSE THEY'RE
ALREADY INJECTING DRUGS AND IF
THEY'RE GOING TO DROP THOSE
DEALS IN THE GROUND THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IT WHETHER OR NOT-
A NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAM.
EXISTS THE IDEA THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE FUELING A SYRINGE
LETTER. WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
FRUSTRATES SAN FRANCISCANS AS
MUCH AS A FRUSTRATED ANYONE NO
ONE WANTS TO SEE NEEDLES ON THE
GROUND BUT- THAT THAT IS NOT
CONNECTED TO WHETHER THERE'S A
NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAM PEOPLE
PEOPLE ARE EITHER GOING TO DO
IT OR THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO
IT- AND HONESTLY LIKE THE IDEA
OF. TAKING SO SEQUEL- IS- THE
IDEA THIS WOULD EVER BE IN
SEQUENCE TO BEGIN WITH IS.
FRANKLY AN INDICTMENT OF. LET'S
SEE WHAT THIS IS NOT A SECRET
ISSUE WHY C. C. WHO WAS AN
ACTOR TO- TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
EVALUATING ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO IMPACT THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT IS. A STRETCH
AT PAST THE SUIT THIS IS A
LEGITIMATE- SYKORA SITUATION
AND SO. CLARIFYING THIS IS
ACCEPTANCE EQUAL I THINK IS A
GOOD IDEA SO I MOVED. THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SERRA WINNER CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER ED TERRIBLE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. SO TO
THE CHAIR- IS THERE ANY ANY
STUDY JUST BASED ON WHAT THE
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID. ANY STUDY ON
THE IMPACTS OF- NEEDLES BEING.
THROWN TO THE GROUND IT IT I
GUESS THE REASON WHY I'M ASKING
IS I KNOW EACH ONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS IS DIFFERENT. AND
JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO JUST SAID THAT SAN
FRANCISCANS ARE FRUSTRATED
NOBODY WANTS TO SEE NEEDLES ON
THE GROUND IN PLAYGROUNDS TO
SPECIFICALLY- WHEN YOU'RE
WALKING DOWN THE STREET. WE
HAVE A- THE KERN RIVER INTO OUR
DISTRICT AND A LOT OF OUR
HOMELESS AND DRUG ADDICTED LIVE
ON THE RIVER SO THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO WATER- TENSE I MEAN
THERE'S CONSTANT GARBAGE ALL
KINDS OF FECES ALL ALONG THE
RIVER BED IT'S JUST A MESS. BUT
WE DO NOTICES THERE'S A LOT OF-
A LOT OF NEEDLES- INVENTED
WITHOUT TRASHING GARBAGE IS
THERE ANY TYPE OF STUDY OR
ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN DONE. ON
THE IMPACTS- THAT THESE USED
NEEDLES ARE THESE NEEDLES THAT
THEY'RE USING- IT HAS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT- THIS SUMMER
VENTILATED YOU WISH TO DRESS
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION AND I'M HAPPY
TO PROVIDE THE SOURCE FROM THE
AMERICAN JOURNAL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT WE DREW THIS FROM.
THE RESEARCH DOES SHOW THAT AS
THE PEAS DO NOT INCREASE
SYRINGE LITTER AND COMMUNITY.
IN FACT PEOPLE WHO OBTAIN
SYRINGES FROM S. C. PEAS FOR
MORE LIKELY TO DISPOSE OF THE
SYRINGES. PROPERLY I WILL READ
A QUOTE FROM THE ABSTRACT THAT
I REFERENCED. BUT IT SAYS THAT
OBTAINING SYRINGES FROM A
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS WAS
FOUND TO BE PROTECTIVE AGAINST
IMPROPER DISPOSAL. AND
INJECTING IN PUBLIC SPACES WAS
PREDICTIVE OF IMPROPER
DISPOSAL. THUS I'M HAPPY TO
GIVE YOU THE SOURCE FOR WHERE
THAT CAN. THAT'S VERY GOOD
INFORMATION I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU SIR FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTION. THANK YOU- CEREMONY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO MY- YOU
KNOW IT'S A COLLEAGUE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY REPRESENTING FRESNO-
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW NAMES BEEN
QUITE THE DEFENDERS SECRET
DURING THE TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND- ALSO BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF. THE SYRINGES
TAKES PROBLEMS IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS AND THAT THEY
PROVIDE AND FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING THE LAWSUITS
AGAINST THESE PROGRAMS WANT TO
ENSURE THAT SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS WENT THROUGH SECRET
COMPLYING ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AND MANY OF THE LAWSUITS ALSO
FOCUSED ON NON SECRET ISSUES-
SUCH AS PUBLIC NUISANCE
CONCERNS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY FIXED BY THIS BILL
SO- THREW THE CHAIR AT I'D LIKE
TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE WHAT FOR
WHAT ARE THE PROCESSES IN
PLACE. THAT THE PROGRAMS USED
TO MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY SYRINGE
LITTER AND ARE THESE MITIGATION
MEASURES CODIFIED IN LAW. OR
REGULATIONS. I'M GOING TO ASK
HER. TO MARRY SOMEONE WHO IS
OUR WITNESS TO COMMENT ON THIS
AS THE EXPERT AND APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS AND- SO. MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON MEMORY CELL UP
BACK ON THE LINE AND- HOPE SHE
HAD OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION
AND- RESPOND. TO THE QUESTION
SEVERAL MONTHS. HI THANKS IT.
YES BY AND REGULATIONS- TO
ADDRESS SYRINGE WEIGHT ISSUES
THE REGULATION THAT IMPLEMENT
THE SECTION THAT WERE AT
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WHAT A MAN
SHARE THAT IN ORDER TO BE
CERTIFIED BY THE PH TO RUN ONE
OF THESE PROGRAMS YOU HAVE TO
SAY GOT THAT LOOK I AM HAPPY
INDICATE HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH YOUR INJURY- IT'S
ALSO THERE IN THEIR LIVES THAT
REQUIRED THAT. HE DISCLOSE THAT
AND IT'S VERY VERY PARTICULAR
WAY IT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE PART BUT RUNNING
A CERTAIN SERVICES PROGRAM TO
PROPERLY DISPOSE THE DIFFERENCE
RIGHT. AND FINALLY- THERE WOULD
REMAIN A NUISANCE CLAIMS WHICH
WERE BROUGHT AND SETTLED THE
LAWSUIT THEY NEVER BEEN
LITIGATED BY A LOCALITY COULD
BRING IN NEW PEOPLE CLAIM IF
THERE WAS A DIRECT LETTER
PROGRAM- PROBLEM DOES THAT
ENSURE QUESTION IT DOES THANK
YOU AND- AND ANOTHER QUESTION
THROUGH THE CHAIR- AND IN THIS
COMPUTER FOR. YOU THIS IS. OR-
FOR THE OFF. ARE THERE ARE
PRETTY NEAT HE'S FOR PUBLIC AND-
TO CALM ON. AS EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS- DO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES EXIST. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THE CURRENT PROCESS
DOES REQUIRE QUICK CONSULTATION
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERSHIP
AND A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD AND
I WILL ASK MARISELA TO PROVIDE
ANOTHER LAYER OF DETAIL- VERY
SILLY. ACTUALLY THE DOCTOR AND-
I HANDLED IT PERFECTLY YES THE
REGULATIONS VERY REGULATION BUT
ALSO ESTABLISHED THAT THAT
PROGRAM MUST HAVE A WAY TO
PROPERLY DISPOSE OF THE
TREMENDOUS. SAYING THAT THERE'S-A PERIOD OF PUBLIC COMMENT IN
CONCORD LET THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ALL AS THAT. SO THE
REGULATIONS IMPLEMENTING
SECTION HAVE ALWAYS BUILT IN A
CONCERN ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY- BOTH IN TERMS OF
SYRINGE WEIGHTS AND- YOU KNOW
PUBLIC OUTREACH. THANK YOU I A.
THE INTEREST. AND YOU KNOW I'VE
STRUGGLED ON WHERE I'M GOING TO
BE BUT I AM GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I DON'T
LOOK FOR SECRET SANCTIONS BUT
IN MY MIND. BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
I READ. THIS IS NOT A SEQUEL AS
MOST OF OUR CONSTITUENTS KNOW
IT- AND I AM A SUPPORTER OF THE
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS- AND
THINK WE NEED TO. ENSURE THAT
THERE IS PUBLIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR
PROJECTS BUT- FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. I'M JUST NOT
CONVINCED SEQUEL IS. MEANT TO
pPROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- I GUESS I
JUST LIKE TO. REFOCUS US BACK
ON HEALTH THIS IS THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HEALTH ISSUES PUBLIC
HEALTH MOST PACIFIC LEE ON THIS
AND WE KNOW. THAT THERE IS A
LARGE INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
A HIV AIDS THAT IS IT THAT THAT
THAT IS CREATED AS WELL AS
ABSENCES AND INJURIES. FROM
DIRTY NEEDLES SO TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A CLEAN NEEDLE EXCHANGE
JUST MAKES GOOD COMMON SENSE.
AND I GUESS IT ALSO JUST AT IT
THIS ALSO GIVES THEM SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE A LOT OF
THEM. CONCERNS ABOUT. NEEDLES
OUT IN PUBLIC WHICH IS WRONG
NOBODY WANTS THAT NOBODY WANTS
THAT AT ALL- THAT ANOTHER
POLICY THAT HAS BEEN BEFORE
THIS. COMMITTEE ON SAFE
INJECTION SITES AND IS NOW
MOVING TO THE OTHER HOUSE
PERHAPS IS. ANOTHER ARGUMENT
FOR. THAT LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THEN IT NEEDLES ARE NOT LEFT
AROUND. AND JUST THOUGHT ON
THAT SAME TOPIC WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT NEEDLES AND AN IV DRUG
USE. WE KNOW RIGHT NOW AND
WE'VE KNOWN FOR AWHILE THAT
FICTIONAL WHICH WAS MOSTLY ON
THE EAST COAST HAS NOW MADE ITS
WAY TO CALIFORNIA. AND SO THE
AMOUNT OF OVERDOSES THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
AND THE COMPLICATIONS FROM THAT
ARE ONLY GOING TO GROW. AGAIN
LEADING TO THE SUPPORT OF A OF
THE SAFE INJECTION SITES BILL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD SO- I THINK
IT INSTEAD THE- INTERESTING
COMMENTS ABOUT ABOUT SEQUEL BUT
I THINK FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
SHOULD STAY FOCUSED ON HEALTH.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- I HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SETON DUMPSTER GROWTH IS YOUR
MICROPHONE UPPER. DECKS ON THE
SHIP OKAY. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- SOME
RAMBLE- I TO THAT STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THIS BILL IS STAN- IF
IT PASSES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WILL
PRIDE PERHAPS MORE CLOSELY
EXAMINED THE SEQUEL ISSUES-
ALTHOUGH I CERTAINLY HAVE MY
OWN OPINIONS THAT THIS- THAT
SEE BECAUSE BEING MISUSED IN
THIS BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT TO
THAT THAT COMMITTEE TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION- BUT I. DO
ALSO WANT TO JUST REINFORCE
THIS BEING THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ASPECTS AND I
KNW IT'S REALLY BEEN DESCRIBED
BY MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
ON THE COMMITTEE- BUT WE KNOW
THAT NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
BRING DOWN THE RATE OF. HIV
HEPATITIS C. THESE CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE USE OF DIRTY NEEDLES
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE DIRTY
NEEDLES- THAT END UP ON THE
GROUND ARE NOT BECAUSE WE GAVE
THOSE NEEDLES TO PEOPLE IT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE USING THE DRUGS
AND THAT'S AND THEN THEY'RE
DISPOSING OF IT IN FACT NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS AS YOU CITED
IN THE IN THE PAPER. ACTUALLY
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF NEEDLE-
WASTE THAT'S THERE SO.
CERTAINLY AREAS DON'T THAT-
DON'T HAVE NEW SCENES PROGRAM
STILL HAVE NEEDLE WASTE. AS AS
WELL- I WOULD ALSO JUST MAKE
NOTE FOR EXAMPLE- TALKING ABOUT
IT SAID THE IMPACT. ON
INFECTION IT IS- THE STATE OF
INDIANA UNDER A GOVERNOR MIKE
PENCE WHO MIGHT HAVE HEARD US-
THAT FINALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY HAD AND RAGING HIV
EPIDEMIC THAT FINALLY THEY- DID
INDEED- EXCHANGE. WHICH FINALLY
HELPED THEM BRING IT UNDER
CONTROL. RIGHT SO WE THINK
ABOUT THE TRADE OFFS HERE-
THERE IS MUCH OF A TRADE OFF
YOU CAN HAVE LESS DISEASE. AND
EVEN PROBABLY LESS WASTE OR YOU
GET MORE DISEASE AND- AT LEAST
THE SAME IF NOT MORE WASTE SO
TO ME IT'S A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD EQUATION. SO
IT'S ONLY UP IN SUPPORT YOUR
BILL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
AT THE MOVIES I THINK IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WINNER- THE
MOTIONS DO PASS THE FIRST.
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S NOBLE
AND DOESN'T KNOW EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AIKEN SOLACE. I CONSULT WITH MY
GROWTH. HER TADO. LLEVA I LIVE
I LIVE MY HI LIMA IROC RIGHT
ROSS HI RUBIO HI RUBIO I WINNER
WINNER I. ONE EIGHT ONE. RIGHT
THROWS CURRENTLY EIGHT ONE WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MIRANDOLA ALRIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO- ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY ONE ONE
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER MAN SHINE I
SEE SOME MEMBER MAN SHINE HERE
SORRY JUST GIVE US A MONTH TO
CLEAN THE PODIUM. ALL RIGHT
WELCOME. VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT A B. ONE
FOURTEEN THE RARE DISEASE
SEQUENCING FOR CRITICALLY ILL
INFANTS ACT. WHEN WE THINK OF
WELCOMING A NEWBORN BABY WE
EXPECT THEM AND HOPE FOR THEM
TO BE BORN HEALTHY HAPPY. AND
READY TO LIVE A FULL LIFE
UNFORTUNATELY SOME INSTANT%
INFANTS ARE BORN WITH CRITICAL
ILLNESSES. THAT REQUIRE SERIOUS
MEDICAL ATTENTION AS SOON AS
THEIR LIVES BEGAN. SOMETIMES
THE CAUSE OF THE SYMPTOMS ARE
NOT EASILY DIAGNOSABLE AND
DOCTORS OFTEN HAVE TO RESORT TO
INVASIVE DIAGNOSTIC TESTS AND
PROCEDURES. IN THE MOST
CRITICAL CASES DOCTORS HAVE
TURNED TO GENOME SEQUENCING. OF
REVOLUTIONARY AND COMPREHENSIVE
DIAGNOSTIC TOOL. THAT EXAMINES
THE STRUCTURE OF A PATIENT'S
DNA. THE SIMPLE BLOOD TEST CAN
POINT TO ABNORMALITIES FOR
EXTREMELY RARE DISEASES. THAT
MAY EXPLAIN THE INFANT'S
ILLNESSES. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AS CO CHAIR OF THE RARE DISEASE
CAUCUS WE SECURED TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE BUDGET
TO FUND PROJECT BABY BEAR. A
PILOT PROJECT THAT EXPLORED THE
BENEFITS OF RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING. IF IT WAS TREATED
AS THE STANDARD OF CARE. RATHER
THAN A LAST RESORT. PROJECT
BABY BEAR SEQUENCED A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT CRITICALLY
IL BABIES ON MEDIC COW AND THE
RESULTS WERE IMPRESSIVE. THIRTY
FIVE RARE CONDITIONS WERE
DIAGNOSED. PATIENTS SPENT AN
AVERAGE OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN FEWER DAYS IN THE
HOSPITAL. AND ELEVEN FEWER
MAJOR SURGERIES WERE PERFORMED.
RAPID WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING
PRODUCE RESULTS THAT HELP
DOCTORS DEVELOP MORE TARGETED
MANAGEMENT. OF PATIENT CARE AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE THE STATE AN
ESTIMATED TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN HEALTH CARE
COSTS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS LIFE
CHANGING TOOL ISN'T. EQUITABLY
ACCESSIBLE. PATIENTS ON MEDI
CAL HAVE NEEDED TO RELY ON
DONATIONS OR CLINICAL TRIALS IN
ORDER TO COVER THE COSTS THE
SEQUENCING. AB ONE FOURTEEN
SIXTY. AT CLOSE THIS DISPARITY.
AND PROVIDE RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING IS A COVERED
MEDICARE BENEFIT FOR CRITICALLY
ILL BABIES WHEN YOU'RE YOUNGER.
RECEIVE AN IN PATIENT CARE AND
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT TODAY- WITH
AT WITH ME TODAY TELEPHONICALLY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR TWO
PIONEERS IN THE FIELD. DR
PATRICK FREAS WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF RADY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND HEALTH
CARE CENTER IN SAN DIEGO. AND
DR STEPHEN KING'S MORE THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF RADY
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE FOR
GENOMIC MEDICINE. RIGHT THANK
YOU SOME REMAIN CHINA MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE-
DOCTORS STEPHEN KING'S MORE
FROM RADY CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE
FOR GENETIC MEDICINE AND- HI
PATRICK. PRVIOUS PRESIDENTS
CEO FREE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL-
YOU EACH HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
TOTAL FOR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
BOTH OF YOU I'LL GET A TWO
MINUTE WARNING FOR THE FIRST
THAT WITNESS IN CASE THEY START
RUNNING OVER. DR PAT YOU ANSWER.
SO IF YOUR PEN AND SENATORS I
THINK I CAN BEST EXPLAIN THE
MIRACLE OF RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING. THAT STORY WHEN HE
WAS A DOCTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF OVER TO A
DOCTOR DR D. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FIRST I KNOW I CALLED
OUT YOUR NAME BUT JUST
INTRODUCE YOURSELF BRIEFLY
BEFORE YOU BEGIN. MY APOLOGIES-
DOCTOR STEPHEN KING'S MORE
PRESIDENT AND CEO. OF RADY
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE FOR
GENOMIC MEDICINE THANK YOU. I
WANT TO EXPLAIN THE MIRACLE OF
RAPID WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING
BY SHARING A PATIENT STORY WITH
YOU. THIS WAS PUBLISHED IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
LAST WEEK. AND GOT VERY WIDE
MEDIA COVERAGE. IT'S A CASE OF
A SIX WEEK OLD PREVIOUSLY
HEALTHY BOY. WHO WAS BROUGHT TO
OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AT
RADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LAST%
OCTOBER WITH INCONSOLABLE
CRYING FOR TWO HOURS. HIS
DOCTOR NOTICED AS NEUROLOGIC
EXAM WAS ABNORMAL. AND ADMITTED
THE BABY AFTER DOING AN
EMERGENCY BRAIN CT SCAN. WHICH
CONFIRMED THAT HE HAD AN
ABNORMAL BREATHING- FILE THE
NEXT DAY HIS MOM AND- CONSENTED
FOR US TO DETAILS OF THEIR
BABY'S GENOME BECAUSE THERE
WERE OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DIFFERENT GENETIC DISEASES THAT
COULD POSSIBLY BE CAUSING HIS
SYMPTOMS THIRTEEN AND A HALF
HOURS LATER WE HAD PINPOINTED
THE CAUSE OF THE BABY'S ILLNESS
IT WAS A RARE GENETIC DISEASE
BUT ONE WHICH IS EMINENTLY
TREATABLE WITH TWO DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS BIETEN AND FIREMAN
WE PROMPTLY STARTED THOSE. BABY
WENT HOME A COUPLE OF DAYS
LATER ON IT EIGHT MONTHS OF AGE
SHE'S THRIVING COMPARE HIS CASE
WITH HIS OLDER SISTER WHO
ARRIVED AT THE SAME EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TEN YEARS EARLIER
NOT BACK THEN WE DIDN'T HAVE A
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING ON THE
DIAGNOSIS WAS NEVER MADE IN HER
CASE SHE SPENT MOST OF THE
ENTIRE ONLY YEAR OF HER LIFE IN
HOSPITAL WITH CONTINUOUS
SEIZURES BEFORE DYING. THAT'S
THE BEFORE AND AFTER THAT'S THE
MIRACULOUS TECHNOLOGY BUT WE
NOW WANT TO MAKE ROUTINELY
AVAILABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL. BABIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANKS VERY.
EVERYTHING'S MORE LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO- DR PATRICK FREAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PAN A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON DR
PATRICK FREAS PRESIDENCY
ALREADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
HEALTH CENTER I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE ONE FOUR
AS YOU MAY KNOW RADY CHILDREN'S
IS THE ONLY ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL
SURGICAL- IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION WE ALSO CARE FOR A LARGE
PORTION OF THE CHILDREN FROM
SOUTHERN RIVERSIDE. COUNTY AS
50% OF THE PATIENTS WE SERVE
ARE MEDICARE ELIGIBLE WE ARE
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THE
EQUITABLE DELIVERY OF
HEALTHCARE AS DR KING'S MORE SO
ELOQUENTLY HIGHLIGHTED RAPID
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING HAS
PROVEN TO BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
CRITICALLY ILL INFANTS AND
CHILDREN AND NEONATAL AND
PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE CARE UNITS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS NORTH
AMERICA THROUGH OUR INSTITUTE
FOR GENOMIC MEDICINE. WALLET
YOU PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES
COVER THE COST OF THE TEST IT
IS NOT CURRENTLY A MEDICARE
COVERED BENEFITS FURTHERMORE
RADY CHILDREN'S HAS BEEN
HELPING TO SUBSIDIZE PAYMENT
FOR THE SEQUENCING OF MEDICAL
PATIENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT IS NOT A SUSTAINABLE MODEL
OUR GOAL WITH AB ONE ONE FORCED
TO INSURE THAT ALL CRITICALLY
ILL INFANTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
FAMILY'S ABILITY TO PAY. HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS LIFESAVING AND
LIFECHANGING TEST WE HEARD
YOUR. I VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANKS VERY MUCH TALK
FREEST WILL MOVE ON TO DIGITAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ONE ONE FOUR BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
GALLERY SAYING NO ONE AT THE
PUBLIC GALLERY TO TESTIFY WAS
MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. THE
NON ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE TELEPHONIC
LINES FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY
ELEVEN FORTY BUT ONE ONE FOUR.
AGAIN NAME OR POSITION POSITION
ONLY. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE TWO THAT ARE IN OUR QUEUE.
OKAY. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYOR MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY ONE ONE FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT IS
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KATY LIED ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS I THE QUEUE ARE
YOU SEEING ANY MISTER RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD WITNESS
OPPOSITION WITNESS FOR
TESTIMONY SO GO TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY ONE ONE FOUR AGAIN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SINGH KNOWN TO
THE PUBLIC GALLERY FOR
TESTIFIED WAS MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. YOU KNOW ROOM A TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TELEPHONIC LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY ONE ONE FOUR NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. AND NOW
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU-
WELL THEY'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OR TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
K. SAYING NONE- THE RAIN SHINE-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- NO GENETIC
TESTING IS- SOMETHING AGAIN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PATIENTS
WHO ARE IN THE I SEE YOU HAVE A
CONDITION THAT'S UNDIAGNOSED
NEWBORNS OFTEN TIMES TODAY
TESTING. CAN MORE RAPIDLY
IDENTIFY OR EVEN JUST SIMPLY
IDENTIFY WE'VE BEEN A BIT ON
THAT STATIC WAS RELATED FOR
STORY THAT. MANY UNFORESEEN
MANY PEOPLE ARE KILLED EVEN ON
DIAGNOSED BEFORE THEY DIE
CHILDREN. WHO HAVE- VERY RARE
DISORDERS A ONES THAT CANNOT BE
IDENTIFIED TO THIS CAN BE A
LIFE SAVING INTERVENTIONS. FOR
CHILDREN- AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND WOULD THAT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH
RIGHT IN EIGHT CIGNA DO NOTE
CENTER GROVE HAS HER MICROPHONE
UP SO EVEN THOUGH YOU CLOSE AND
IF YOU THAT'S ALRIGHT I'LL
PERMIT HER TO ALSO- TESTIFYING
ASK QUESTIONS. JUST GOING TO
MOVE THE BILL SIR- EXCELLENT
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GROVE. ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTION
IS- DO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I AIKMAN RIGHT AIKMAN
ARKANSAS'S. CONSOLE ON A GROVE.
GROVE I HER TADO LLEVA. I LIVE
IN I LIVE ALONE AND THE MOON I.
ROSS. ROSS I RUBIO HI RUBIO. I
WINNER. WINNER I. OKAY FIRST
ALL THE BILLS THAT ZERO AND
EVERYONE'S THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR- EIGHTY TWO
FORTY FIVE SUMMER RODRIGUEZ
DOES HAVE TO WAIT A MOMENT FOR
THE CLICK CLEAN PODIUM. OKAY
THE SUMMER RODRIGUEZ WELCOME.
WELCOME THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A B. TWO FORTY AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WOULD
EXAMINE THE STATUS OF THE WORK
FORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE OF
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. I
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO AND FOCUS ON THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IT INFRASTRUCTURE.
I THANK THE STAFF IN THE CHAIR
FOR YOUR COLLABORATION. SINCE
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING DAY IN AND DAY OUT
PROVIDING CRITICAL CARE TO
THOSE IN NEED. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN
CONTROLLING THE SPREAD AND
INCREASING. VACCINATIONS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS CREDENTIALS THAT
WE WERE NOT PREPARED TO RESPOND
TO COVERT NINETEEN. A. B. TWO
FORTY OR GREATER PROCESS TO
EXAMINE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE ISSUES
BY REQUIRING THE CDPH TO
CONTRACT CONTRACT WITH OUR
PROPERTY IN THE DETAIL VALUE
WAIT AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON ADEQUATE STAFFING LEVELS.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. THIS
WOULD ENSURE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS CAN PERFORM DAILY
ACTIVITIES OF PREVENTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DURING TIMES
OF EMERGENCIES ADEQUATELY FLUX
TO MEET EMERGING COMMUNITY
NEEDS. SUCH AS DURING A
PANDEMIC. AS CALIFORNIA MOVES
FORWARD TO RECOVER FROM COVER
NINETEEN WE MUST EXAMINE AND RE
EXAMINE HOW LOCAL. PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE STAFFED
RESOURCE. WITH ME TODAY PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IS MICHELLE GIBBONS
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND MARY JANE DEALS
WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA. HI THANK
YOU SO MUCH SOME MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ A MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE. DEUS FROM
THIS YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL INITIAL GIVEN FROM THE
COUNTY OF COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA- AT LEAST IN MY
SHEET I HAVE MERRY DE IS GOING
FIRST THIS BUT YOU HAD SAID IN
REVERSE ORDER SO I DON'T KNOW
WHO'S- WHO'S TESTIFYING FIRST.
I GET AFTERNOON YOU'RE MEMBERS
WITH MICHELLE GIVEN THEY'LL GO
FOR IT AND WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE THAT THAT
FEATURE THAT CALIFORNIA. ONE OF
THE PROGRESS ON THE MAYBE TWO
FORTY- CULMINATING ILLUSTRATED
HOW PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICUM
IMPACT THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ADVERSELY
IMPACT. FACTORS RANGING FROM
HEALTHCARE SCHOOLS BUSINESSES
FRANKLY THE WHOLE ECONOMY. OUR
COMPANY CAN ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
HOW IMPORTANT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE THE WORK IS THE
FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE AGAINST
THE PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS AND
PREVENT OUTBREAKS REDUCE
CHRONIC DISEASES. ADDRESS
HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
ADMINISTERED PROGRAMS AIMED AT
PROMOTING HEALTHY EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. IT
LIFTING BAN AND TO. BY TRUST
FOR TOP. PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORTS
IN OUR NATION HAS BEEN
UNDERFUNDED BY FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION. BECAUSE OF THIS EVEN
PRIOR TO KOBE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LACK SUFFICIENT
STAFFING AND OPERATED WITHOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY AND REPORTING.
WE HAVE TO PAY THAT WHEN PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK IS INVISIBLE SO
IT'S EASY TO FEEL THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS ADEQUATELY STAFFED
AND HAVE A STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER
CULMINATING REVEALED THE NEED
TO FURTHER UNDERSTAND AMBLE
THROUGH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. EIGHTY TWO
FORTY WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONTACT WITH AN APPROPRIATE
ENTITY TO A VALUE IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND WE
CAN MEAN THINK HOLDERS TO HELP
INFORM. INCLUDING
IDENTIFICATION OF BARRIERS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ADEQUATE
STAFFING APPROPRIATE
CREDENTIALING ACCESS TO
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION SUPPORT IN
INCENTIVIZING A PIPELINE OF
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE EVALUATION
WOULD ALSO AFFECT THE EFFICACY
OF HEALTH INFORMATION TOOL AND
I USED TO BE PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY CAPACITY AND
EVALUATE RECENT TREND WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING STREAMS AND THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO SUSTAIN
WORK OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. AND THE GROWING
DEMAND FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. AS WELL. A REPORT
AND THE RECORD. AND TRAINING
WOULD BE PRO TO THE- AS WELL.
IT IMPORTANT THAT WE KNOW
REPEAT THE MISTAKES OF THE PAST
IN ORDER AVOID UNDER AN IN THE-
WE MUST UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
MEANS HAVE AN ADEQUATE AND WELL
PREPARED. A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THAT THAT. EVEN IF
THEY ARE SEXUALLY- YEAH VOTE ON
A IN FORT. THANK YOU IT OVER TO
MY FROM. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
SO NOW BRING ON MERRY I DO FROM
S. THANK YOU DR PAM SENATORS
MARY JANE ACTS YOU HAVE THE OF
AN THERE YOU GO. REPRESENTING
YOUR LOW TOWN PUBLIC HEALTH THE
WORKS SHE AND PRAGUE ON OF
EIGHTY TWO POINT. AND MICHAEL
FROM JACK. THE VOTING ON CLUB
HEALTH IN FISH AND WORKFORCE
ARE NOW. NOW MORE THAN EVER SHE
IT'S A BIT BIGGER LAST WE
LEARNED THE PANDEMIC. EIGHTY
FORTY WERE CREATED. TO THAT WE
CAN COLLECT YOU ACCOMPLISH
EVALUATION WENT BACK. ON HOW
POWER CAN FINALLY BUILD UP OUR
LOCAL PUB HEALTH. FASTING AND
INTO. AND YOUR KNOW UNDER THE
HAS BEEN AT THE CALL FOR THAT
YOU CAN CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACT THAT WE DON'T IN
A EROSION OF THE WORK. THANK
YOU EXPERTS. CLINICAL AND BE TO
THAT BRITAIN AND I MAKE. YET
FIFTY ONE HOW JUICE. AND
WORKERS HAVE BEEN TWENTY FOUR
CENTURY THREATS AND NEED
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES GROUPS
ARE AND WALK TOWARDS THE TWO.
THE BATTLE. THE STATE AND LOCAL
NEED TO ON THE RECRUITING AND
WITH. OF THE MODERN. PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FOR WITH THE
NECESSARY TO. ANNEX ALONG SIDE
OP BILL UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THE LAB THE FACILITY. AMONG
OTHER TO ENSURE THE WHOLE IF
SOMEONE. DIDN'T TO FORTY IS
CRITICAL WILL BE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. AND IN MANY TO
BETTER ON THE ACT ACTUAL MEANS
OF OUR LOCAL QUICKLY. DIRECTOR
THEY CAN TAKE A- PUBLIC POWER.
TOWARD AND PUBLIC CHANGES APART
FROM AND BACK FOR THE NEAR
FUTURE. FOR THIS REASON WE
REQUIRE YOUR EYES ON YOUTUBE
THANK YOU. THANKS MUCH NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO DO WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO FORTY GO
TO PUBLIC GALLERY C. NOT GALA
MOVED TO ROOM.
ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE CURRENT
MEMBERS COLD FORMERS ON BEHALF
OF SAN BERNADINO COUNTY COURT
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTY AT THE CALIFORNIA THE
ROYAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY- HERE IN THE PARK. THANK
YOU NEXT TIME. NEXT IS THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACTUALLY
BETTER WITH THE HELP OF THE
THIRD THE THIRD SEASON OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO LINE A ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA THANKS FOR PRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
IS ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HERE ROBERT HALF OF THE
CITY OF PASADENA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXLINE. ONE ONE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CRYSTAL KIOSK ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY IN NEVADA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR BAND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDON MARCHING AT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE
ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBER
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OFF
THE MARK MERCK- ON THE HOP ON
YOUR COFFEE COUNTY IN YOUR
COUNTY AND YELLOW COUNTY
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS JESSICA MORAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE WITH THE NATIONAL
VOCATIONAL ALSO WORKED OUT A
POIGNANT CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO
LINE ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT WHEN YOU
CAN'T DO ANYTHING. THIS IS NOT
DONALD LIVELY CALIFORNIA OF
MEDICINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. BUT WE DID HAVE ONE
MORE JOIN UP TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. IT LOOKS LIKE THEY
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR NO
MOVE T WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWO FORTY- WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED SO WE WILL GET THEN MOVE
TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY SELLING
SEEN ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
ROOM ONE TWELVE C. KNOWN ROOM
TWELVE. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO FORTY NAME.
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
HAND OUT HERE OPPOSITE TO A B.%
TWO FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
IN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER
CENTER GROVE AND MOVED THE BILL
SIR RIGHT THOSE BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GROVE A CENTER RUBIO.
FOR QUICKLY I WANTED TO GET
THERE FOR FREE AS FAR. AT I
WOULD LIKE BE ADDED AS A CO OP.
I WHAT WE- DURING. THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WAS THAT WE
LACKED INFORMATION AND THAT'S
JUST SO POWERFUL TO SEE HOW WE-CAN DO THINGS BETTER SO WITH
THAT I'LL SURGEON I VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE. THE SERVER RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I KNOW WHEN I WAS-
CHAIR OF THE BUDGETS OF COMING
OUT AND EVEN SERVICES TWENTY
EIGHT C. PH. AND OCCASIONS-
FAST ABOUT- WORK FOR STUDY WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN DECLINED
THE WORK FORCE. IS GONNA BE SO
VERY IMPORTANT HPEFULLY- WE'RE
GOING TO BE A MAKE PROGRESS
THIS YEAR WITH BOTH THE BUDGET
AND WHAT YOUR BILL. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOUR
MENTOR FOR CLASS RIVAL THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT SO THE
MITIGATION BEEN MOVED BY CENTER.
THE MOST IS DUE. AS AMENDED THE
FIRST REFER AND THEN- AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI AN HIGH
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I AIKMAN
ALL RIGHT A MAN I CAN SOLACE BY
THEMSELVES I GROWTH. HI GROVE I
HER TADO LEVER HI. LEAVE A
HIGHLY MOON. THE MOON I. ROSS.
ROSS I RUBIO. HI RUBIO. I
WINNER. WINNER I. THE BILL IS
OUT TENS. THANK YOU THANK HERE.
RIGHT SO- I AM THE FIVE EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE. IS THE HELD.
AND SO LET'S MOVE ON ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHT THREE TWENTY
SIX SUMMER. REAL WE- AND- JUST
GIVE A MOMENT TO CLEAN PODIUM
HERE. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO MEMBER
LOUIS REAVIS WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
THREE TWENTY SIX THIS BILL
REMOVES THE SUNSET DATE ON THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE FOR D. M. H. C. D.
NH C. REGULATES THE MAJORITY OF
HEALTH COVERAGE POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ONE OF THEIR
CORE MISSIONS IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS HEALTH CARE EVERY
YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE
INTRODUCES ON AVERAGE FIFTY
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
AFFECT THE DEPARTMENT AND EACH
MEASURE COULD AFFECT THE TWENTY
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS SERVED
BY THE DEPARTMENT. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO THE CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT FULFILL THEIR
MISSION AND ENSURE CONSUMERS
HAVE A SAY IN THEIR HEALTH CARE%
INSURANCE MEDICAL RECORDS AND
MEDICAL DECISIONS SINCE THE
PROGRAM WAS CONSIDERED NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
APPLIED TO THE PROGRAM. AFTER
ALMOST TWO DECADES IN EXISTENCE
THE CONSUMER PROGRAM IS NO
LONGER NEW AND EXPERIMENTAL BUT
RATHER A WELL DEMONSTRATED AND
SUCCESSFUL TOOL FOR PROVIDING
CONSUMERS AN IMPORTANT ADVOCATE
IN THEIR CORNER. TO DATE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I HAVE JOSE TAURUS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA. THANK THANK
YOU MODERATOR PLEASE BRING JOSE
TORRES CASSILLIS FROM HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA- YES YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MATURED MEMBERS HOLDING FORTH
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH FROM A
POIGNANT STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE
CONSUMER ADVOCATES COALITION WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THE
FOUR EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX
WHICH WOULD REMOVE. THAT FIVE
YEAR SUNSET FROM THE CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND MAKE THE PROGRAM
PERMANENT. AS MENTIONED BY A
FAMILY MEMBER TO BE BY THE
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO AND IT ALLOWS ME
TO DIRECTOR JOEL WARD
REASONABLE ADVOCACY AND WHAT
FEES TO ANY PERSON OR
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
THE INTERESTS OF CONSUMERS. AND
HAVE MADE A SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTION ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS TO THE ADOPTION OF A
REGULATION ORDER OR DECISION BY
THE DIRECTOR IT IMPACTED.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OVERLY.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED AWARD HAPPY.
TRACK RECORD. REPRESENTING AND
LOW CONSUMERS. RIGHT AND WE.
WITH THE WAR IN THE NORTH
INCLINATION HAVE ABLE PARK IN
IN PROGRAM IT SHOULD BE ON THE
OF THE ON TOPIC SUCH AS THE
MERGE BETWEEN THE HEALTH AND
DAY NOT ANTHEM CIGNA AND OTHER
TOPICS BUT AS ANY ACTIVE
REGULATION. AND DEPARTMENT WILL
MAKE REGARDING I DON'T HAVE
RESCISSIONS AND REAL. WHEN THE
PROGRAM WITH THREE IN HIS TWO
WITH NEW EXPERIMENTAL. HAS A
FRIEND MORE TIMES AND I NEARLY
TWENTY YEAR IN NO LONGER KNEEL
EXPERIMENTAL. IT ALLOWS
CONSUMER RECORDS AND INFECTED
IN IN THE MAKING A DECISION.
I'M A PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
SHOULD BE MADE PERMANENT THE
DEAN. FOR THESE REASONS YEAH
FOR YOUR I. ABOUT THANK YOU. X.
NAME OR POSITION POSITION ONLY.
HANLEY GERMAN PR IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. SECOND ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. WE HAVE TO DO IN
OUR QUEUE RIGHT. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA ONLY
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN PORT AND
CRITICAL THINKING THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AT THE TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH W WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY SIX WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS FOR
TESTIMONY STILL GO TO THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC ALICE MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEN ON JUNE TWELFTH.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION ONLY. NOW
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL BING IT BACK TO TOO MANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE-
SO THAT'S EVER LOSE REPEAT
ITSELF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- THIS IS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND NOW WILL
BE ABLE TO LET IT CONTINUE-
WITHOUT SUNSET- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. RIGHT THANK
YOU DESERVE THE OCEAN. OKAY
IT'S THE CENTER LABOR'S MOVED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS- ITS OWN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S NO AIKMAN.
I ATE WHEN I CAN SELL THIS HI
CONSEILLERS I GROVE. HER TADO
LLEVA HI LISA I. LOVE THE MOON
HI THE MAN I. ROTH IRA ROTH IRA
RUBIO. RUBIO I. WINNER OUR
WINNER I. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE YEAH. RIGHT THE ONE.
OKAY SO THE RAW IS EIGHT ONE
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
THREE FIVE SUMMER SOLACE I
THINK HE'S ON HIS WAY ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT AFTER FOLLOWING THAT
WILL BE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY ONE BY SUMMER BERMAN CELL
I GUESS WE'LL- TAKE A LITTLE
STRETCH BREAKERS WERE WAITING
FOR. AUTHORS AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT DECEMBER SOLACE
IS ON HIS WAY SO HOPEFULLY WILL
BE HERE SHORTLY. I GUESS SO
ACTUALLY. ARE PEOPLE HERE WHO
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE PREVIOUS
BILLS WE CAN LIVE CALLS. YES I
CAN DO OKAY WELL YEAH GO AHEAD
LIVE CALL FOR LEADING SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN ADD ON HERE SO I
WILL WAIT FOR SOME MEMBER.
SOLACE WE'LL GO WE'LL GO BACK
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR-
BY SOME MEMBER RANDALL- I
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HER TADO THE MONTH HI THE MOON
I. OKAY EIGHTY FOUR IS OUT
EIGHT TWO LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THIRTEEN
pCONSULTANT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. HELLO HER
TADO. OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT EIGHT ONE NO.
SILVERMAN'S HERE. OKAY I SEE A
SUMMER BERMAN'S READY HERE DO
WE KNOW THE SALIS BUT THERE IS
OKAY ALL RIGHT YOU IN ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT LET'S MOVE ON NOW
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE SUMMER SALIS
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PROBABLY TAKING TO MAKE THE
ADMINISTRATOR TITLE CONSISTENT.
WITH REFERENCES TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATOR TO OVERSEE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS. ESTABLISH OUTCOME
INDICATORS INTEGRATED CARE AND
STANDARDIZE GERIATRICS TRAINING
AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. ONE IN FIVE
OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCE MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS HOWEVER LESS
THAN ONE THIRD OF ALL OLDER
ADULTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH ACTUALLY
RECEIVE IT. UNDIAGNOSED AND
UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OF THE SERIOUS IMPACT FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
FROM NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
SITE 58% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF SUICIDES. FOR THOSE AGE
SIXTY FIVE TO EIGHTY FOUR AND A
50% AND 50% FOR THOSE EIGHTY
FIVE AND OLDER THAT'S COMPARED
TO AN AVERAGE OF FORTY EIGHT
POINT 8% INCREASE STATEWIDE FOR
ALL AGE GROUPS. SUICIDE RATES
ARE PARTICULARLY HIGH IN RURAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA WERE ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE WAS
SEVERELY LACKING. IN CALIFORNIA
THE OLDER ADULT POPULATION WILL
INCREASE SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. BY
THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TO
TWELVE MILLION ADULTS AGE SIXTY
AND AOVE. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE US CENSUS BUREAU PROJECTS
SENIOR CITIZENS WILL OUTNUMBER
YOUTH FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY. A STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA CENTER
FOR HEALTH POLICY RESEARCH
FOUND A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
AND DEFICIENCIES IN THE CURRENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STRUCTURE FOR
OLDER ADULTS. AND THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT BY
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE LEADER
IN THIS AREA. WITH THAT I DO
HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE WE HAVE
DR- JANET FRANK A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
AND ONE OF THE LEAD AUTHORS OF
THE STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTH. POLICY AND-
SURELY CRAWLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CAL SENIOR LET. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH A SUMMER
SOLACE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PULLING ON PLEASE BRING ON TO
THE LINE JANET FRANK FROM THE
FIELDING SCHOOL UCLA FIELDING
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
SURELY CROWN TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE WILL BEGIN
WITH- A- DOCTOR THE DOCTOR
FRANK- FROM. MANTA YOU HAVE
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES- AND IF
YOU RUN OF YOUR TWO MINUTES
THAT. TOLD THAT TAKES AWAY TIME
FROM THE SECOND PERSON TO KEEP
IN MIND I'LL GIVE A TWO MINUTE.
I'LL GIVE YOU A SIGN WHEN I HIT
YET TWO MINUTES SO- CODE PLEASE
BRING ON JENNA FRANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANET
FRANKEN I'M PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. I AM A
COMMISSIONER AND ALSO WOMEN
FACULTY AT THE UCLA SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE IS SUPPORTED BY
RESEARCH AND WILL ALSO PROVIDE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT
TO THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND
INNOVATIONS. UNDERWAY FOR
MEDICAL AND MEDICARE. IN
CALIFORNIA. WE COMPLETED A
STUDY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON
OLDER ADULTS AND WE FOUND
SIGNIFICANT UNMET SERVICE NEEDS
AND GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES
ACROSS THE STAGE. WE FOUND FEW
PROGRAMS TAILORED FOR THE
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS OF OLDER
ADULTS. THOUSANDS OF MEN AND
DATA WERE LIMITED AND VARIABLE
BY COUNTY. AND IMPORTANTLY
THERE WAS A LACK OF LEADERSHIP
AT THE STATE FOR OLDER ADULTS
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
OUR FINDINGS WERE SUPPORTED BY
A DATA REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNCIL. A
THE ESTIMATE SEVEN THOUSAND
OLDER CALIFORNIANS IN NEED OF
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH. ONLY
4% RECEIVE SERVICES IN FY
EIGHTEEN. OLDER ADULTS ARE 16%
OF THE ADULT MEDICAID
POPULATION YEAH LESS THAN 3%
RECEIVED EVEN ONE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE. THE BILL
ALSO SUPPORTS THE MASTER PLAN
ON AGING- SPECIFICALLY THE HELP
REIMAGINE GOALS AND ELSIE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS BEGAN
THIS DECISION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE IN PLACE. THE
OFFICE OF MEDICARE INNOVATION
AND INTEGRATION AIMS TO BE
INNOVATIVE MODELS AND THIS
PROPOSED POSITION WILL BE A KEY
RESOURCE TO THIS EFFORT AS WELL
AS THE EFFORTS IN CAL AIMS. TO
CALL FOR A NEW ADMINISTRATOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTEGRATION
STATEWIDE IN THIS SITUATION
IT'S IMPORTANT. FOR BATCH- ALSO.
AS EMPHASIZED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE SITUATION IS DIRE
AND REQUIRES IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION. RIGHT NOW NO ONE HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP THE
SYSTEM BECOME MORE RESPONSIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS REGARDING MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND WITNESS ACTUALLY
CROWNED. YES MY NAME IS SHIRLEY
GROWN AND I AM A SENIOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
MY PRESENTATION TODAY WILL
PROVIDE BACKGROUND ON MY
RESEARCH INTO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES HERE IN CALIFORNIA BASED
ON FIFTEEN PLUS YEARS OF BEING
ON THE BOARD OF SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUSING ON THIS
ISSUE THIS LED INTO CREATING
THE PROPOSAL AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
INCLUDES MANY OF THE FINDINGS
FROM THE UCLA STUDY PRESENTED
BY. DR FRANK. MY RESEARCH
INVOLVED MAKING CONTACT WITH
SEVERAL COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS WHAT I DISCOVERED
IS THAT UNDERSERVED OLDER
ADULTS WE'RE FACED WITH THE
ABSENCE OF COORDINATED SERVICES
WHICH MEANT THAT THERE WAS POOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCONSISTENT
REPORTING CRITERIA HOWEVER.
SOME COUNTIES PREPARED PLANS
REQUESTING FUNDING BUT WHEN
FUNDS WERE SUPPLIED THE
ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY USE THEM
FOR OTHER PROJECTS NOT MENTAL
HEALTH THIS TOLD ME THAT THERE
WAS VERY LITTLE. OR NO
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH IN MY
OPINION IT IS UNACCEPTABLE IN
ADDITION TO THE ISSUES FACING
UNDERSERVED OLDER ADULTS I
BEGAN TO SERIOUSLY UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTS OF. MENTAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IMPACTING
THIS POPULATION LONELINESS
ANXIETY DEPRESSION SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND END OF LIFE ISSUES IN
ADDITION TO SHELTERING IN PLACE
SOCIALIZED IN ADDITION SHELTER
HIM PLACE SOCIAL ISOLATION FEAR
ANXIETY ALONG WITH- ALONG WITH
HIM- ENGLISH CAPABILITY AND A
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE EVERY
TECHNOLOGY IDENTIFIES MORE
ISSUES. FACING THIS POPULATION
ACCELERATED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC IT WOULD BE THREE TWO
THREE IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THESE ISSUES AND
INCLUDE SOME CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ASPECTS FOR EXAMPLE
STANDARDIZED GERIATRICS
TRAINING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS THAT WOULD COVER
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC AND FIXED.
GEOGRAPHIC AND DIVERSE. AMONG
THIS POPULATION. AND- GOD. I'M
ALMOST DONE. THERE NEEDLESS TO
SAY CREATE THE POST OF A ADULT
MENTAL SIR ADMINISTRATOR AS
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
STATE LEADERSHIP. OKAY SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PASS THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT NOW WE'LL MOVE
ON TO THIS NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE AGAIN THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON AT THE BIKE FOR THE
PUBLIC OUT IT'S MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE C. KNOWN ROOM
TWELVE. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR PEOPLE WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE V. THREE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. N. ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN
THE QUEUE OKAY. WE'LL START
WITH THE LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTOR TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THEM AND
IT'S CONDITION THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERM MEMBER SHERRY
DELUDED CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JOHN PORTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE ARE YOU HURT YOUR
YES VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD WITNESS LISTED FOR
TESTIMONY SO WE'LL GO BACK TO
THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERIES MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE SINGLE ROOM TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TWO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. NOW IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER
ADMIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
WOULD LIKE THE AUTHOR FOR THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I WOULD MAKE THE MOTION AS
WE ALL KNOW THAT- THE AMOUNT OF
OLDER ADULTS CONTINUES TO GROW-
AND THE- OF THE SUBSIDY TO BE
ABLE TO. I HAVE A HAVE A ONE
STOP FOR THEM AND TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AND M.
IMPERATIVE AS WE ALL MOVE
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC SO WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THIS BILL AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK IN THIS
AREA. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
ADMIN- UNDER THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SIR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AND I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND TO KEEP IT
SHORT I'LL- TACKLE. EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THING KILL. THANK YOU. LETTER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SAYING NONE- I TOO APPRECIATE.
THE WHAT TRYING TO THE BILL AND
BEING SURE THAT WE HAVE-
SOMEONE JUST FOCUS ON OUR-
AGING POPULATION- FOR TO MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS I WOULD JUST. MAKE
NOTE THAT- THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN RAISED ABOUT THE
FUNDING SOURCE- AS WELL BUT- I
THINK FROM A POLICY POINT OF
VIEW WERE ALL GOOD. YOU'LL DEAL
WITH THAT WITH THAT. WE FINALLY
GET TO. TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT. AT THAT POINT
BUT- BUT THAT CERTAINLY WOULD
SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST TAKE ALL THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AS MY
CLOTHES AND THINK- SORT OF RIO
FOR ADDING ON AS CO AUTHOR AND
HAPPY TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE ON AS
WELL. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
PRIVACY OKAY EXCELLENT SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SIR EDMUND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST. AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES- CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CAN I CAN I
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN
ARKANSAS FIVE CONSOLES I GROW
HI GROVE I HER TADO FLAVOR. THE
MON HEY ROSS FOR THE MON I ROSS
I RUBIO I REVIEW I WINNER FIVE
WINNER I. YEAH OKAY THE BILL
CHARLIE EIGHT ZERO HOLD THE
LONG COUGH THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THE MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
ONE BY SUMMER BERMAN WELCOME
AND- SO I WOULD GIVE A MOMENT
TO. CLEAN THE PODIUM. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON THERE'S MAYBE
FIVE FORTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAMS
TO ASSESS ALL PATIENTS FOR
TOBACCO USE. AND OFFERED
PATIENT TREATMENT OR A REFERRAL
TO TREATMENT FOR TOBACCO USE
DISORDER. INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS ARE MORE THAN TWICE
AS LIKELY TO SMOKE CIGARETTES
AS INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT SUCH
DISORDERS AND ARE MORE LIKELY
TO DIE FROM TOBACCO RELATED
ILLNESS. AND FROM THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITION
THAT BRINGS THEM TO TREATMENT.
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
NOTES THAT SMOKING IS
ASSOCIATED WITH GREATER ODDS OF
RELAPSE. AND THE CDC RECOMMENDS
THE INTEGRATION OF TOBACCO
TREATMENT INTO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
RANKS FORTY FIRST IN THE UNITED
STATES ON ASKING ABOUT TOBACCO
IN THIRTY SECONDS ON PROVIDING
TOBACCO TREATMENT COUNSELING
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT- I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY. THE DEFINITION OF
TOBACCO TO INCLUDE ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS REFER TO THE MOST
RECENT DIAGNOSTIC CRITERIA FOR
TOBACCO TOBACCO USE DISORDER.
AND CLARIFY THAT TREATMENT IS
SUBJECT TO THE LIMITATION OF A
PROGRAM'S LICENSE. OR
CERTIFICATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
DECEMBER BERMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH ME TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS- WE HAVE A MODERATOR
WE SHOULD HAVE TWO WITNESSES ON
THE LINE AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT KATHY MCDONALD FROM
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY O ADDICTION
MEDICINE. AND JENNIFER- CAPELLO
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER COSTS
UPON MERA SO WE BEGIN WITH THE
DOCTOR KATHY MCDONALD AND YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES OF TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN BOTH OF
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR DR
KING ON THE NUMBERS. THIS IS
DOCTOR CAPTAIN MCDONALD I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AN ORGANIZATION OF
SEVEN HUNDRED PROFESSIONALS
DEDICATED TO OPTIMIZING
EVIDENCE BASED. SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT FOR OUR
PATIENTS AND FAMILY. WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR- AND FAMILY
BERMAN. AND BERMAN EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES A
COMPUTER STORAGE FACILITY
WITHOUT THE CLIENT FOR TOBACCO
USE INFORM PATIENTS HOW
CONTINUED TOBACCO USE CAN
AFFECT THEIR RECOVERY. AN
OPPORTUNITY OR REFERRAL FOR
TREATMENT OF TOBACCO USE
DISORDERS. AS YOU HEARD ARE
THERE ARE EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH
RATES OF TOBACCO USE AMONG
YOUTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
PATIENTS IN THE RANGE OF 70%
COMPARISON 211% IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. AND THE CDC REPORT
THAT A FAMILY MEMBER AND
MENTIONED. HIM STRAIGHT A POOR
SHOWING ON THE PART OF
CALIFORNIA RELATIVE TO OTHER
TREATING THAT IN SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT. IT CLEAR THAT
THE IS SOMETHING JUSTICE ISSUE
AND THAT- TOBACCO USE DISORDER
AS WE KNOW DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. IN SETTINGS
WHERE STAFF IS TRAINED TO TREAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IT IS.
OVER TIME TO BACK A DEPENDENT
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
PEOPLE IN RECOVERY. NO JACK WAS
OFTEN PARTS OF THE PLAINS
PATTERN OF USE OF OTHER
SUBSTANCES AND SERVED AS A
POWERFUL. POTENTIAL TRIGGER TO
REALIZE. HI YOUR NO THAT'S
ABOUT TREE AND STOP FUTURE
TREATMENT SETTINGS HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO BE. INCREASED THEIR
SUCCESSFUL RECOVERY FROM THEIR
OTHER SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
BY 25% AND THAT THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT QUITTING TOBACCO
DECREASES STRESS AND DEPRESSION.
BILL WILL HELP BOTH IN
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT TO GET TREATED FOR
TOBACCO USE DISORDER THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE. AND IT
WILL PREVENT HELP TO PREVENT
RELAPSE TO TOBACCO USE IN A
PERSON WHO ENTERS THE PROGRAM
HAVING STOPPED USING TOBACCO.
YEAH YOU HAVE A HIGH FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. TAKE A
LOOK HE LIVES NOW BRIANNA
JENNIFER CARVALLO FROM COSTS OF
PALMEIRA AND YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND FORTY NINE SECONDS. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE I'M
JENNIFER CARBALLO CEO A COUPLE
MERRIMACK CHEMICAL DEPENDENCY
RECOVERY HOSPITAL AND AN
EXECUTIVE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS THE CAP. AS
SOMEONE IN LONG TERM RECOVERY I
WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO GO TO
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT IN THE
LATE NINETIES WHEN I WAS
ADMITTED I WAS OFFERED
CIGARETTES REPEATEDLY BY STAFF
I HAD RECENTLY QUIT SMOKING AND
THE TEMPTATION WAS GREAT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE FACILITY
WAS CLEARLY TOBACCO FRIENDLY.
STAFF WITH MOCKING WITH CLIENTS
IN BUYING FACTOR FOR PATIENTS
THE MESSAGE WAS THAT TREATMENT
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER IS
STRESSFUL ENOUGH WITHOUT ALSO
ADDRESSING WITHDRAWAL FROM
NICOTINE ADDICTION. IN THE
WOMEN'S ONLY FACILITY THERE
WERE TWO CONSTANTS THAT SMOKING
WITH OUR CORPORATE
SOCIALIZATION AND THAT SMOKING
A COLD STRESS RELIEF GRANTED I
WAS INTRIGUED THEM MANY YEARS
AGO BUT NOW IS THE LEADER IN
OUR INDUSTRY I THINK THAT WE'VE
BEEN SLOW TO ADOPT BEST
PRACTICES. AROUND RECOGNITION
AND TREATMENT OF NICOTINE
ADDICTION CERTAINLY HELLO IN
CALIFORNIA'S OUR STATE RANKS
LOW ON TOBACCO TREATMENT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE THE
PATIENTS WE TREAT IN
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS ARE QUITE
LIKELY TO HAVE NICOTINE
DEPENDENCE CENTER PLAYED BY THE
IMPACT OF THAT DEPEND AS LONG
AFTER BEING TREATED FOR THEIR
PRIMARY DIAGNOSIS. SIMPLY
RECOGNIZING IS THAT STILL PUTS
FORTH THAT NICOTINE ADDICTION
IS IMPACTFUL AND PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR TREATMENT WHAT
ENCOURAGES SUPPORT OF POLY
SUBSTANCE FREE RECOVERY
NICOTINE IS CERTAINLY AN
ADDICTIVE DRUG OF CHOICE AND
THERE ARE MULTIPLE DELIVERY
PERCENT. CIGARETTES PIPES AND
CHEWING TOBACCO AND SADLY NOW
THEY WHICH ARE PROBLEMATIC ON
SO MANY LEVELS FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITY HI PORT
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY ONE AS AN
ENTRY LEVEL TOBACCO
INTERVENTION FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
SCREENING AND BRIEF
INTERVENTION AS OPPOSED TO MORE
SIGNIFICANT CALL TO ACTION.
SUCH AS MANDATING NICOTINE FREE
FACILITIES. THIS IS A STEP
TOWARD NORMALIZING TOBACCO FREE
FACILITIES AND EVIDENCE BASED
TOBACCO FREE POLICY WILL HELP
GUIDE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INDUSTRY AND PROMOTING WELLNESS
OVER STRESS. RELIEF ABSTINENCE
OVER OBJECTS TION AND HOW OVER
TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TO. AND YOUR I. THANK YOU
WHEN MOVE ON TO DESTROY THIS IS
A OF A FIVE FORTY ONE- WILL TO
THE PUB GOING PUBLIC. WILL MOVE
ON TO ROOM ONE TWO SINGLE ROOM
AND- MODERATOR OPEN THE LAW.
WITNESSES WHICH TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
ONE. YEMEN TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FIVE FOUR ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR IN OUR
QUEUE. START WITH LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LITERATURE NUMBER CONNIE
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. COMPLINE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD- MY NUMBER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
MATTEO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE DAVID
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU
NOW WITH THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
ONE WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. LISTED HERE
SO WE'LL GO TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE OUGHT TO MAKE FOR
THE PUBLIC ALICE MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY ONE NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. NOW IF
YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION DAY B.
FIVE FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO PROPOSITION.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO ONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OR THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NONE OF US ARE BERMAN- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I THINK FOR THE
COMMITTEE CLEARLY- SO YOUR
WITNESSES OF RATE- ARTICULATED-
TOBACCO ITSELF IS AN ADDICTIVE
SUBSTANCE AND- THAT ASSESSMENT-
THAT CAN LEAD TO A- MEDIA
INTERVENTION WILL HAVE TO BE
VERY HELPFUL. WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU CHEERS LAST
OCTOBER AND THEN I WANT TO
THINK MY CONSTITUENT DOCTOR IN
G. CHAN FOR BRING THIS ISSUE TO
MY ATTENTION AND RECOMMENDING
THIS LEGISLATION RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH IS THERE A MOTION IS MOVED
BY CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU ON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAND. HI CAN I
MELINDA'S. A EGGMAN I SOLACE HI
CONSOLES I GROUP OF. HER TADO
LLEVA I LEAVE I LEAVE MON HI
THE MOON I ROTH ROTH IRA RUBIO
HI RUBIO I WINNER. WINNER HI.
OKAY GROVE I. OKAY THE BILLS
CURRENTLY NINE ZERO HELPED HOLD
ON CALL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THE FAMILY WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVEN SEVEN BY SUMMER CERVANTES
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AN ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN I WANT
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
BILL BUT BEFORE I DO BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE POLICY ONCERN.
REGARDING THE DEFINITION OF
INTER PREGNANCY INTERVAL. EARLY
PREGNANCY LOSSES A SHOCKING AND
TRAUMATIC EVENT FOR WOMEN AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS A SOCIETY WE
DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE LOSS TO THE-PARENTS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY TO
THE MOTHER. THE DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY EXPERIENCED BY MANY
WOMEN AFTER MISCARRIAGE CAN
CONTINUE FOR YEARS EVEN AFTER
THE BIRTH OF A HEALTHY CHILD.
DESPITE MISCARRIAGES BEING A
COMMON OCCURRENCE THEY'RE STILL
HIGH DEGREE OF STIGMA
SURROUNDING MISCARRIAGES AND
MANY WOMEN ESPECIALLY BLACK AND
BROWN WOMEN FIND THEMSELVES IN
AN ISOLATING GRIEVING PROCESS
THEIR EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS OFTEN GO
UNMET. AS WE SEEK TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
REDUCE THE ADVERSE OUTCOMES A
PERSISTENT MATERNAL DEPRESSION
IT IS NECESSARY THAT WE ENSURE.
THAT INTER PART INTO KERR IS
CONSIDERED A PART OF THE POST
PARTUM CARE WHEN SCREENING THIS
EITHER OFFERED OR PROVIDED.
ENTER PREGNANCY CARE WERE
OFFERED TARGETED SUPPORT DURING
PREGNANCY TO WOMEN WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED PREGNANCY LOSS WHEN
MEDICALLY INDICATED AND ENSURE
EARLY RECOGNITION OF SYMPTOMS
THAT MAY BE ABLE TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR BOTH WOMEN
AND THEIR CHILDREN. ALL WOMEN
DESERVE QUALITY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE INCLUDING ANY WOMAN WHO
HAS BEEN PREGNANT REGARDLESS OF
THE OUTCOME OF THEIR
PREGNANCIES. A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH TO INCLUDE INTER
PREGNANCY CARE TO ENSURE THAT
MOTHERS IS SEEKING ASSISTANCE
HEALTH CARE OR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS INCLUDE WOMEN WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED MISCARRIAGES.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE CURRENT LAW
CLEAR AND ADDRESS THE
COMPLICATIONS OR MEDICAL ISSUES
THAT DEVELOP DURING PREGNANCY
ESPECIALLY AFTER MATT
MISCARRIAGES OR STILLBIRTHS. TO
ASSESS THE WOMAN'S MENTAL INTO-
WELL BEING WITH ME TO IN
SUPPORT CHERYL HART DIRECTOR OF
SUPPORTING MAMA'S. THANKS VERY
MUCH AS A MEMBERS AROUND TASTE-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING CHERYL
HART FROM SUPPORTING MAMA'S ON
TO THE LINE PROVIDE TESTIMONY
SUPPORT YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU CAN ADD UP TO TIME BY
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CHERYL HOT TIME THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COACHING MOMENT
A NONPROFIT I FOUNDED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
SOCIAL SUPPORT FOR WOMEN WITH
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL ENSURE THAT WOMEN WHO
EXPERIENCED MISCARRIAGES CAN
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING IMAGE. I HERE TO
TELL BETWEEN SUBSEQUENT
PREGNANT UP TO ONE YET OPTION.
EXPERIENCING THE LOSS OF A
PREGNANCY OR BABY TO
MISCARRIAGE OR STILLBIRTH BRING
UNIMAGINABLE PAIN AND GRIEF. AS
MANY AS POSSIBLE PREGNANCIES
MAY END IN MISCARRIAGE WE DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER BECAUSE
THE MISCARRIAGE MAY HAPPEN
BEFORE WOMANIZER PREGNANT. ONLY
20% OF WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCED A
MISCARRIAGE THE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE DEPRESSION AND OR
ANXIETY. IN THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE AFFECTED THE POTENTIAL
ONE TO THREE YEARS THE DAILY
IMPACTING QUALITY OF LIFE AND
SUBSEQUENT PREGNANCY. YOUNG
BLACK CONNECTS AND BY PUT WOMEN
AND THOSE OF LOWER SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS HELLO THANKS
FOR THE CALL. OKAY SKILLS ARE
AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH COMPLICATIONS. A
RECENT SURVEY FOUND THAT ONE IN
THREE WOMEN HAD SYMPTOMS OF
PTSD ONE MONTH AFTER THE
MISCARRIAGE AND ONE IN THREE
HAD SYMPTOMS OF MODERATE OR
SEVERE ANXIETY WE SUSPECTED
FIGURE S ACTUALLY MUCH HIGHER
DUE TO LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENING UP FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS. AND THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED. WITH MISCARRIAGE
UNTIL THE- AFFECTED MOTHER OPEN.
TO STICK MY AND MUCH THEY INTO.
THAT STILL BLAME WOMEN THAT
MATTER. AND OFTEN MOTHERS
EXPERIENCE DOT NET AND SHAME
WHEN THE FEELINGS OF BOTH LAW
AND MOTHERHOOD WHEN NOTHING
KNOWLEDGE. FOLLOWING A
MISCARRIAGE WOMEN HAVE PROVIDED
LITTLE SUPPORT AN OPEN
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH.
SCREENING IS NOT COOL. REMOVAL
OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN MEANS THAT MANY MORE
WOMEN WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THEY SO
BADLY NEED. DURING THE PAINFUL
GREETING CARDS THAT ARE GOING
TO NAVIGATE GOOD PREGNANCIES
FOR TREATMENT THE COURT AND
HEALTHY COPING STRATEGIES I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO SAY REGARDING
EIGHTY ONE POINT SEVEN SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERIES WITH ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEN ON ROOM TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVEN SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AT
THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED
FOR TESTIMONY SO WE'LL GO TO
THE PUBLIC GALLERY FOR PEOPLE
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVEN SEVEN. THE END SCENE ON A
PUBLIC ICE WITH ROOM ONE TWELVE
SINGH KNOWN ROOM TWELVE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVEN SEVEN.
NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO PROPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT- NOW WILL BRING IT BACK
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE- CENTER ADMIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD JUST LIKE
GOT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS- I THINK WE DON'T THINK
ENOUGH ABOUT THE- THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IMPACT ON ON- ON MOTHERS
WHETHER THEY'VE HAD A LIVE
BIRTH OR NOT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW THE
IMPACT OF A POST- POST. NATAL
DEPRESSION HAS SEVERE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES SO I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL THANK YOU BY TARA MAN
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE- NASIR SERVAN
TASTES I TO- I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
WERE FOR AT LEAST FOUR FINALLY
DEVELOPING SOME AWARENESS
ALTHOUGH I THINK WE CAN STILL
DO BETTER ABOUT POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION BUT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DRESS AND EVEN ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT I'M FORTIES TOO OFTEN
HIDDEN I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A
MEDICAL STUDENT AND WE LEARNED
ABOUT MISCARRIAGES AND THEN
REALIZE HOW FREQUENTLY THEY
WORK BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T TALK
ABOUT IT RIGHT- BUT- DEAR
DIRECTOR ACTUALLY STEALING
FREQUENT- AND SO- WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS I KNOW THE TERM
INTER PREGNANCY WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSING. I GUESS THAT IS THE
TERM THAT'S BEING USED
RECOGNIZING THAT SOMEONE CAN
HAVE A MISCARRIAGE INSIDE NOT
TO GET PREGNANT AGAIN IS ALSO A
PARTICULAR CHOICE BUT THAT
WOULD STILL APPLY TO THEM SO IT
WASN'T CLEAR ABOUT THAT I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND US TRYING
TO STRANGLE THAT AND BE SURE WE
USED RIGHT DEFINITIONS- BUT
WITH THAT- SERVICE SUPPORT YOUR
BILL WHICH IS LIKE THE CLOTHES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AGAIN- A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WILL
IMPROVE OUR STATE'S EFFORTS TO
REDUCE MATERNAL MORBIDITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. RIGHT THANK YOU AND SO
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
EGLIN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE%
APPROPRIATIONS SECOND TONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN. HI
ANAHEIM MELINDA'S. I MY- I
EGGMAN GUY EGGMAN ARKANSAS. HI
CONSULT. I OF. HER TO. LLEVA
LEAVE I LEAVE ALONE HEY LEE MON
I ROSS. ROSS HI RUBIO HI RUBIO
I WINNER. BY WINNER I. GROVE I
OKAY. YEAH OKAY SO YOUR BILLS
OUT TEN ZERO OKAY BY NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
THREE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY TWO BY SUMER
WALDRON I ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY TWELVE EIGHTY BY SOME
MEMBER IRWIN AND I AND NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SUMMER SERVAN TASTES
IS OUR MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OKAY MOVE I CENTER
LLEVA A CONSULTANT- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND HI CAN I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I AIKMAN BY ADMIN I
CAN SOLACE HI AND SO AS I GROW.
HER TADO LLEVA LABOR EILEEN MON
HI THE AMOUNT I ROTH ROTH IRA
RUBIO HI RUBIO I WINNER. WINNER
I. OKAY SO. NINE ZERO OKAY SO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENTLY
NINE ZERO HOLD THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL SO WE'LL GO
BACK AND- LIST CALLS MEMPHIS
CENTER. GROVE IS THERE YOU ARE
OKAY. I THINK ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA BEGIN LIFTING CALLS.
RIGHT SO I THINK WE START WITH
I THINK ITEM NUMBER. SIX
SEVENTY FIVE THE ACCESS ONE.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX- THAT
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX BY SOME
MEMBER LOUIS REAVIS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROF GROVE NO OKAY FOR
TARA. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX IS OUT
EIGHT TWO. NEXT ITEM IS THE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE BY SOME MEMBER
SOLACE- CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF AT OPEN THE ROLE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. MELINDA'S
HI MELINDA'S I HER TADO. LEAVE
AT LEVI. OKAY EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE IS OUT TEN ZERO. I
AM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER
BERMAN- CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S. OKAY EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY ONE IS OUT NINE ZERO-
NEXT ITEM IS ITM NUMBER THREE
TIPS. IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVEN SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBERS AROUND TASTE-
ECOTONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AT
LEAST THAT'S OUT READY TEN ZERO
SORRY OKAY SO NEXT FINALLY IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- PLEASE-
LIST THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS. GROSS HI GROVE HI HER
TADO. OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT TEN ZERO. OKAY
WELL- THIS CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
OF THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH- I JUST
WANT TO FIRST OF ALL THANK
AGAIN THANK THE STAFF AND THE
TECHNICAL STAFF- FOR YOUR HARD
WORK. AND THESE HEARINGS AND
BEING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SMOOTH HEARING PEOPLE OF OPTI
TESTIFY- SOMEWHAT THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND WITH THAT- THIS HEARING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
IS A JERK.